well no winners hey Ron I'm Abby Sharpe
welcome to Abby's kitchen and I'm back
with my friend Abbie Langer how's it
going good well maybe not so good soon
so we are back trying some of your
favorite diets and it's looking pretty
unappetizing in this home thanks guys
all right so we got some apple cider
vinegar here this is the good stuff this
is a nutrition myth that just won't quit
won't quit downing this stuff in some
kind of attempt to burn fat doesn't work
people it just burns your tooth enamel
yeah so let's do it they did a research
study where they found that you know
people did have a lower appetite after
the APUs mm-hmm you don't but that's
because they were feeling like they were
gonna throw up I'm totally salivating
like the pre mom it is the preval the
préval is that enough is a great way to
turn yourself off and off your appetite
like lipstick I don't know what to do
about it I don't know what to do about
it
I'm already I'm already in this deep but
the only reason to actually consume
apple cider vinegar they have found for
people who have diabetes that it may
help to reduce blood glucose up a really
high carb meal but let's be honest like
your endocrinologist may love you but
your dentist is gonna want to kill you
don't do it don't do it look what I look
at me do you want to look like look at
her baby food time we are regressing to
the
laughing this is apparently like really
this was made famous by Tracy Anderson
and people like Jennifer Aniston like
they swear by this diet so these ladies
must hate their lives it's basically a
juice cleanse but a lot less sexy and
disgusting when I start seeing
cold-pressed baby food bars
I'm not leaving we're totally that's
gonna happen no don't say it don't give
somebody out the idea cuz someone out
there on YouTube is gonna take that and
run with it should do it oh my god no
all right
okay let's do that one let's do the meat
first and then we'll wash it down with
something a little more palatable
oh I love them give me some squash beans
and squash why don't you just get
yourself some Carina mmm seriously no
you the farro squash is not good had my
daughter actually gagged when I tried to
feed her this so that was last time oh
no I'm not eating that
look at me I know baby that pink fish
stuff but we're adults we've had poutine
and doughnuts and bacon and pizza like
we can't regress to this anyways this
works because the low calorie diet
there's no magic about it
No portion control low calorie
especially because like no one is gonna
want to eat the beef with the broth so
you're basically just living on unlike
low low low cal vegetables it's like the
Ritz like raw till 4 but wait word one
jar of the butternut squash is 45
calories I mean it's a starvation diet
really yep all right Abbi so a lot of us
have probably been on Instagram and seen
those before and after photos of the you
know it works rats so basically what
these things tell you to do is wrap
yourself in this botanical cloth these
woven cloth the people tentacles leech
into your skin and obviously you just
wake up the next morning and you're like
skinny they're super expensive they're
like a hundred bucks each
we looked into it trust us but we just
figure if we could DIY this and we feel
a lot of great recipes
Pinterest there are DIY raps yeah what
we've got here is some plastic wrap some
lotion to lube ourselves up and some
tensor bandages
so let's do this just kind of get a
little Lube action this is the step one
now plastic wrap so the tighter the
better Mike okay like really tight my
last baby is over eight pounds this'll
fix it don't worry Abby get it nice and
tight we can't let that what's that fat
escape it's got to get sucked in with
the botanicals look at it's like waist
training all right almost there almost
there look realistic
I know it's mildly uncomfortable so now
I guess we just go to bed and wake up
this just nowhere to go oh well you
wouldn't want to get intimate because
it's like like started sexually take off
your shirt and then just like wow let's
do it and cocktail while we're at it I
need to forget what just went down so if
you liked what you saw be sure to
subscribe to my channel and give me the
thumbs up and leave us a comment below
about whatever kind of crazy diet you
want us to try out next and I'll see you
next time in Abby's kitchen